how do you feel about women being
stay-at-home moms and not bringing in an
income after they have a baby do you
feel like that is an unwise financial
decision no it's an important season no
one should shame a mom for wanting to
work at home because that's what it is
it's not like you're eating bonbons yeah
I'm like oh my God you're not staying
anywhere you were running something
would you add to that as a professional
model yeah I mean I would say you're
saving on child care there was a study
that was run the mileage the average mom
drives the food that she cooks the house
that she cleans if you were to Outsource
all of that 1.2 million dollars